kann schon ein gleich noch kurz
einkaufen gehen damit egal globus oder
ich brauche babynahrung und hinten auf
dem feld kanada verkaufen schwanger nein
nein ich sehe hier kein baby nahrung für
mich gestellt da steht
warum eigentlich mache hundekekse wir
haben auch keine not ja aber unser team
ok wollte das baby nahrung ja sie wohnen
einer kartoffel ok einmalig gab
kartoffel karotte gibt es eine mischung
ok und rindfleisch gibt so kleine
gläschen kann ich das mischen und
einmalig hundekekse finden sie am markt
und für also nicht fernsehen hat für
sein hobby gemacht ich hab die
leberwurst kekse die ist über die ndl
habe ich kümmere mich ist alles bereit
ist fertig war und dann mit offenen
facebooks karotten
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich backe heute an der theke ja also
keine kekse die aussehen wie ein hund
sondern kekse für kunden bei uns im team
hat irgendwie jeder einen hund also
wirklich jeder ausnahmslos und da hab
ich mir gedacht kommt meine schwester
komplett abend nehmen ihren hund mit
gepackten heute einfach mal 100 kekse
und von der zubereitung her sind alle
auch ein bisschen unterschiedlich das
heißt ihr habt entweder mal so zutaten
oder eben auch den tipp mit den baby
gläschen zeitgleich wir starten jetzt
erst mal mit leberwurst keksen
dafür nehmen die 100 gramm leberwurst
das ist eine geflügel leberwurst zweier
200 g mehl und dinkel vollkommen ist das
und ich habe ich noch einen teelöffel
sonnenblumenöl also nur vier zutaten und
der vorteil von diesem selbst gemachten
hundekissen ist ihr könnte theoretisch
auch selbst helfen wenn ihr wollt muss
aber nicht ja die geflügel leberwurst
das darf die echt nicht sehen denn sie
liebt die 100 prozent geflügel und
wahrscheinlich wird sie die kekse
probieren wenn ich sage die eier mit
rein also wirklich alle zutaten einfach
rein
die schüssel soll er aus aber das was
drin
und jetzt kurz mit dem handrührgerät
verrühren oder auch mit dem händen
kneten
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig doch echt ne schöne
konsistenz und ich nehme jetzt ein
bisschen mehr auf meine matte wird
ausgerollt und jetzt soll ich den teig 5
mm dick aus da habe ich jetzt hier
dieser abstand rede anderem aus hall
starb
[Musik]
das lege ich hier mein backblech mit
dauer back folie aus und kann jetzt
kekse ausstechen
da könnt ihr euch natürlich
ausstechformen aussuchen ich habe hier
eine hundepfoten eine katze einen
knochen
ich glaube leberwurst kekse mache ich
herzchen und der vorteil von diesen
abstand zu reden ist einfach dass jetzt
der teig gleichmäßig dick ist 5 mm das
heißt beim backen haben sie auch alle
die gleiche backzeit weil oft kein mann
sein rad beim plätzchenbacken da ist der
teig außen etwas tun damit der dicker
und dann packen sie unterschiedlich
teilweise werden sie im ofen dann so
dunkel und die anderen bleiben noch zu
hell und so habt ihr wirklich alles
schön regelmäßig keller freut sich über
die leberwurst kekse ich finde es eine
schöne portion
sollte plätzchen sind fertig habe ich
noch ein bisschen rest habe einfach vier
kugeln gemacht die rolle ich jetzt auch
noch 5 mm dünn aus so müsst ihr den rest
nämlich nicht wegschmeißen kommen
sondern können sie wirklich komplett
verbrauchen und jetzt kommen die
plätzchen schon in den backofen und ich
zu alt sie und sagen schon die hundekeks
in den backofen und ich zeige euch
gleich die nächste sorte
super aus schön weich perfekt
[Musik]
das zweite rezept braucht ihr nur drei
zutaten
ich habe hier 500 gramm dinkel
vollkornmehl habe jeweils 250 gramm
babybrei und zwar einmal rindfleisch und
einmal kartoffel karotte ihr könnt es
natürlich auch einfach selber kochen
kartoffeln und karotten abkochen
rindfleisch abkochen und dann ganz fein
pürieren und hier werden jetzt einfach
die zutaten kurz verbunden aber wenn ihr
eben sagt 'mensch dass es mir jetzt zu
viel arbeit nehmt einfach die bläschen
die sind auch gut ich muss sagen mein
kind würde ich das jetzt nicht
verfüttern zur rindfleisch aus dem glas
aber ja ist bestimmt ganz gut da kommt
jetzt noch der karotten kartoffel breit
dazu der ist nicht mal schlecht da
müsste jetzt im prinzip nur darauf
achten dass es einfach mischungen sind
ohne knoblauch und ohne zwiebeln
knoblauch und zwiebeln für hunde nicht
gut sind und jetzt kürzeren
stress könnte ich jetzt einfach kurs mit
den händen ein
den rolle ich jetzt auch wird auf 5 mm
dick aus
[Musik]
da nehme ich jetzt die hundepfoten
und damit das förmchen nicht klebt
vorher kurz in meldungen und dann
ausstechen
wir sind jetzt auch schön fertig bei
heißluft könnt ihr übrigens einfach
gleichzeitig packung zwei bleche einmal
oben einmal unten und bei heißluft
einfach immer 20 grad weniger als bei
ober unterhitze wählen
[Musik]
für das nächste rezept brauche ich
karotten die brauche ich jetzt auch gar
nicht schälen etwas parmesan käse einen
telefon und wieder mail dann nehme ich
wieder das dinkelvollkornbrot die
karotten die können die entweder selbst
klein schneiden und kochen ihr könnt sie
auch dünsten oder ihr könnt auch
karottenbrei wieder aus dem glas nehmen
also ganz wie ihr wollt
ich werde jetzt ganz fein hobeln bzw
feinschneiden und die karotten könnte
jetzt entweder fein hobeln fein
schneiden und dann kochen oder einfach
im dampf backofen oder im dampfgarer
kurz dünsten und am ende brauche ich
etwa 250 gramm gekochte karotten
jetzt hier einfach einen dampfgarer 100
grad und ich denke so in 20 minuten sind
die auf jeden fall weich und dann werde
ich sie einfach nur noch parieren
[Musik]
die karotten die pure ich jetzt einfach
mit dem öl
[Musik]
du bist hier noch bisschen wasser dazu
damit etwas breiter wird ok jetzt mal
ganz im ernst was ist das für eine farbe
das sind karotten aus dem glas doch sind
selbst gekochte karotten schon krass
das ist schon fast rot bis da war es
dass ich und das gebe ich in die kirche
und kann ich hier auch die zutaten
einfach alle miteinander verbinden
den parmesan habe ich jetzt bereits
geschrieben ganz bringt was mich jetzt
wundert hier ist halt die karotten masse
etwas flüssiger da etwas fester
das heißt mit der menge bei dem
flüssigen brauchte etwas mehr mehl und
beim selbstgemachten etwas weniger mail
aber da gucke ich jetzt einfach gleich
das einfach schöner fester teig entsteht
so wie gerade eben auch
[Musik]
und hier steche ich jetzt kleine häschen
aus mit häschen gerne karotten ist
[Musik]
diese vegetarischen kekse sind im
prinzip auch die perfekten kekse für
kleinkinder
denn ich habe nur karotten mit drin
vollkornmehl und parmesan amazon ist ein
toller kalzium spender dh es können auch
euren kindern geben wenn es morgen ich
lasse sanierer und murat probieren die
sind echt süß bereit für den backofen
und hier will ich jetzt auch wieder halt
luft dann kann ich beide gleichzeitig
wachsen
[Musik]
unsere kekse gebacken und wer muss
gedacht wer könnte besser die hundekekse
probieren als kunde haben wir hier
einmal die marie und in moshi moshi ist
der hund von semak marie von meiner
schwester frau wir uns mal aus hat drei
verschiedene xsara machen zeigt mal wie
du das machst auf wie ich nehmen steckt
ein kind wünschen still
[Musik]
guck mal markiert das zdf mit
rindfleisch max und wie schmeckt so
vegetarisch war gut rindfleisch war gut
machst du auch leberwurst kann dir eine
rolle also kann etwas anderes singen
maria singer geklaut probieren sie
schmecken andere das im rindfleisch käse
probieren
schmecken ganz mobilen leberwurst kekse
und schmeckt jetzt mal lief super
[Musik]
ich glaube beiden schmecken die kekse
sehr gut und ella auch ist echt auch ein
ganz guter kinder snack und vielleicht
macht ihr die rezepte ja nach probiert
zu gerne mal aus und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß dabei bis zum nächsten mal